foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror doing another book review today
so some of you guys might remember a
while back I don't remember how long ago
it was it was quite a while ago
I did actually read and review
um and actually uh really really loved a
2016 murder mystery that was called
Magpie murders by the British author
Anthony Horowitz who is very very
prolific he doesn't just write novels he
also writes uh for British TV like you
were for Midsummer murders and like a
bunch of big you know mystery TV shows
over there so I'm pretty sure that I
mentioned in that first review that
there was actually kind of like a sequel
to Magpie murders
um which came out in 2020 and which I
was really interested in reading so then
we jump ahead to a couple weeks ago you
know summer of 2023 is when I'm
recording this and I was wandering
around a books a million uh one Saturday
afternoon when I came across this right
here this hardback copy of the very
sequel that I was talking about which is
called moonflower murders and I think it
was only like five bucks or something
like that it was in like the front
bargain section and I was like oh and as
you know I got all excited because I was
like oh my God I read Magpie murders and
I loved it so much and I have a
paperback version of that so yeah I
actually do have a physical copy of the
book this time you guys I didn't
actually put it in the I try to take a
picture of it with the um to put in the
thumbnail but it's like it just kept
glaring like in the light and everything
and I was just like [__] it I'll just
put like a digital one in there like
usual but I do actually have the book
this time I didn't read it on Kindle
unlimited and that's just because I
found it like I said in the bargain
section and I have been wanting to read
it and it was super cheap so I was just
kind of like hooray so I just uh bought
it you know what I mean now I have to
say that I loved this book every bit as
much as the first one which was Magpie
murders uh it is structured similarly
but it's a whole new story technically
it's stories because it's kind of it has
the same like book within a book format
as Magpie murders did which like I said
if you want to go back and watch that
review like where I kind of talked about
that and it does have like some kind of
crucial references to the events of the
first novel although I will say that you
don't necessarily have to have read
Magpie murders first like to get into
moonflower murders and like understand
what's going on but I actually would
recommend doing that because there are
you know several connected threads like
I said you don't you can enjoy this on
its own like as a standalone but I think
it's like a much better experience if
you read both of them and really they're
both so good that it's like why wouldn't
you want to um I mean I had a really
good time with both of them so so much
like The Magpie murders uh the first and
last you know like long sections of
moonflower murders are told from the
first person POV of the book editor
Susan Ryland now after the horrible [__]
that happened at the end of the first
novel which like I said if you haven't
read it I don't really want to spoil it
um her life has kind of gone off in a
different direction a little bit uh she
actually no longer works as a book
editor and she's actually moved from her
home in London to Crete and she's
running a hotel with her longtime
boyfriend and uh Andreas now she likes
it like she's having a good time and
Crete is beautiful and everything like
that but she still still feels like
something is missing in her life and she
kind of Misses England a little bit and
she misses her former work because she
was really into reading and she was
really into being a book editor and she
isn't also there's kind of a thing where
she isn't entirely certain uh that she
wants to stay with Andreas even though
she still loves him dearly um she's kind
of like at a Crossroads a little bit so
into this I guess what you call like a
quagmire of dissatisfaction and
ambiguity like going on in her life so
arrives something of kind of like a
blast from the past I guess we had
thought that Susan uh was done with her
very cantankerous and also now very Dead
uh prize author Alan Conway who was a
character in The Last novel
um but it would appear that he is not
entirely done with her uh even if only
in a very indirect way even though he's
like I said pretty dead so what happens
Susan is contacted or she's approached
actually in person in um on Crete by an
English couple who were named Lawrence
and Pauline trehern
and they own this kind of fancy hotel in
Sussex which is called branlow Hall
now they tell her you know eight years
ago this man named Frank Paris was
horribly horribly murdered in his room
at this hotel he was like actually
beaten to death with a hammer
now his body it turned out was
discovered like right in the middle of
the wedding of their daughter Cecily um
which was actually being held on the
hotel's grounds you know on the premises
now the thing about it
this murder was apparently solved almost
immediately
so the culprit was ostensibly uh this
employee at the hotel who was like this
Romanian guy with a very long criminal
record whose name was Stefan
Stephen cut rescue as I think you how
you pronounce his last name I mean like
there was a ton of evidence against him
so like the victim's blood is found in
his room like um he had supposedly stole
some money from the victim and they
found that in his room like stuffed in
his mattress or something
um his fingerprints were on the doorknob
of the room that the guy was in which
was room 12 and also the night desk
clerk thought that he saw Stefan because
like I said he knew him because he
worked there like kind of creeping
toward where the spot where the crime
occurred you know what I mean and as if
that wasn't damning enough uh Stefan
actually confessed to the crime so he
was summarily imprisoned so he's in jail
um so you know Polo case open and shut
or at least so it seemed Cecily trahern
though the daughter you know of the
hotel owners she actually never believed
that Stefan was guilty and she evidently
found confirmation of this belief in a
very unlikely place
it was actually in a book by Alan Conway
who like I said is the author you know
that was in the first novel it was one
of his books like his Atticus pun series
punder it hasn't umla out so it's like
the German pronunciation but that's like
uh that's one of his names so one of his
like big detective novels which like I
said was kind of like a big which Susan
edited you know what I mean
so the book that was called actually
called Atticus pund takes the case right
now Alan Conway it should be noted had
stayed at branlow Hall after the Frank
murder took place like eight years ago
and actually Loosely based his novel
moonflower murders on it and he actually
used a bunch of the real people involved
like as characters in the book
um you know he changed their names and
stuff but they were still like pretty
identifiable so like a lot of the people
uh that worked at the at the hotel were
like really pissed off because he had
stayed there and he's like oh I totally
won't write a book about this place but
then he did and well a lot of the um
depictions of the people and like I said
they were pretty identifiable were uh
really not all that flattering so people
were really not um too happy with the
dude you know so after she read the
novel Cecily called her parents who I
think were like vacationing abroad or
something and she was like kind of
panicking and she's like I'm sure now
that Stefan didn't kill Frank Paris and
she's like I'm gonna send you guys a
copy of this book because there was like
a whole thing with distribution and like
it was hard to get hold of and stuff
like that it's like not important so
she's like I'm gonna send you guys a
copy of this book so you can see for
yourself like what I figured out by
reading this the implication here being
that Alan Conway the author knew who
killed Frank but had like encoded the
information in the book for some reason
instead of like telling the police what
he knew so you know so there's kind of
like a mystery of like why he would have
done that
now the mystery of this one though is
that not too long after Cecily made this
phone call she completely disappeared so
the Trey Hearns her parents who own the
hotel they suspect that Cecily perhaps
Knew Too Much about the Frank Paris case
and subsequently vanished because of it
and the cops are not really being a big
help in this regard
so the parents are just really desperate
for answers so they offer to pay Susan
the book editor ten thousand pounds if
she'll actually come to the hotel and
interview all the all the people there
and read through the book to find out
what it was that Cecily discovered and
they're like whatever clue like she
figured out obviously they can't talk to
Alan Conway himself because he's dead
but they figure that his editor Susan
Ryland is the next best thing because
she was more familiar with his work than
anybody so Susan very reluctantly uh
kind of agrees to this Mission she's not
super happy about it uh it's mostly
because she needs the money like to fix
up some stuff around her own hotel like
back in Crete she's actually not really
sure how much help she's gonna be she's
like I'm not a detective and that's not
this isn't really my area of expertise
you know what I mean but she is actually
kind of willing to give it a shot you
know so Susan goes to branlow Hall and
starts meeting you know just the vast
array of suspects that are there all of
whom you know just like is the case in a
lot of these kind of mysteries uh all of
whom seem to have something to hide
so she spends quite a while kind of like
gathering information about the murder
of Frank Paris and The Disappearance of
Cecily trahern and then she decides that
she's like well I think now that I've
kind of gathered all this information
and interviewed all these people now
it's time for me to like revisit
moonflower murders the novel that Alan
Conway wrote which she had actually
hadn't read for several years so she
needed to like reread it to like
familiarize herself with it so at this
point in the book just like happened in
Magpie murders we delve into Alan
Conway's like fictional mystery story
which is somewhat inspired by the real
murder of Frank Paris and the frame
story but is also pretty different like
the book within a book which actually
has its own title page its own
publication credits its own page
numbering like right in the middle of
this big book right here it's set in
1953 and it tells the story of this kind
of famous American actress whose name is
Melissa James and she bought this
Charming hotel which is based on Braylon
Hall but it's called the moonflower and
it's actually in Devon in the story but
eventually she gets strangled to Death
In Her Bedroom by an unknown assailant
so just as in the Mainframe story like
everybody surrounding the fictional
murder is like sketchy as [__] and many
of them had motive to bump off Melissa
James so this story is actually like
really fun also like in its own right
it's different enough from the real
murder in the frame story to make it its
own thing but because you know that
there's like a clue or clues about the
real murder buried in there somewhere
you end up kind of like reading it with
sort of like an Eagle Eye to try to
figure out what information it was that
Cecily read in there that maybe perhaps
might have gotten her killed so like I
said I mean moonflower murders is every
bit as fun and every bit as satisfying
as Magpie murders was and I liked in
this one that you actually got to spend
a lot more time with the main character
Susan at the beginning of the book as
she started like kind of diving into her
investigation
um you know since the fictional Alan
Conway book doesn't actually start until
I think like a little bit past the
halfway mark because I think in Magpie
murders you know you only had like a
chapter or two with Susan and then it
delved into the fictional mystery and
then you went back to the end now just
like the previous book
um the resolution also of both Mysteries
is very twisty and very surprising but
once revealed like makes complete and
total sense like oh yeah obviously
that's like the only way that it could
have been even though you didn't really
guess it ahead of time I mean I
certainly didn't so I mentioned this too
in my review of Magpie murders please
know going in that the book is
essentially going to switch gears and
kind of go off in a totally different
but somewhat related Direction like a
related story in about the middle so it
might take a little while to get
reoriented like when the fictional
Mystery Begins and also when you return
to the frame story like toward the end
like in the last third but I mean this
wasn't really an issue for me because
like I said I've read Magpie murders and
I did know that this was structured
similarly to that so I was like
expecting it now I do admit that I had
to like kind of flip back a couple of
times to like remember some details from
the main frame story like once I
returned to it like toward the end of
the book so yeah I mean if you love both
just old school like Agatha Christie
style Murder Mysteries and also modern
Mysteries this is kind of like it's
really good because it's like a two for
one you kind of get both things like in
the same story so yeah so just like
Magpie I would totally recommend this
one as well it's kind of full of all the
same really entertaining like plot
twists and all the red herrings and
stuff that you would want like in a
classic mystery and I also really like
the character of Susan and also the
fictional detective Atticus pund uh
who's you know in the fictional part of
the book I mean they're both very
appealing characters they're very well
delineated they're very sympathetic and
they're you know both struggling to
solve their respective puzzles and
they're like I said the puzzles are sort
of related but they're different enough
that they're kind of their own thing but
also kind of the same thing if that
makes any sense you know it's really
easy to see why this book
um you know just like Magpie got so many
rave reviews it was all you know I think
it was on the New York Times list and
all that kind of stuff and it's really
easy to see why it's just really really
fun it's just a complete blast I had a
really good time with this and I'm
really really glad that I found it uh
really really glad that I bought it and
that I have you know a nice hardback
copy of it because I don't usually get
that anymore so that'll do it for this
tomes of Terror thank you very much for
watching please remember to like share
comment and all of that other kind of
stuff it's always good for the algorithm
and I'll see you guys again on the next
one bye